here's a very interesting story about
damage to the Trump brand now I don't
want to be confusing here because in
total the presidency has been very
profitable for Donald Trump and his
family they've continued making hundreds
of millions of dollars in total much of
it they've made by using their positions
of power and privilege in the Oval
Office to make that money Trump's
hundreds of trips to play golf at his
own golf clubs for example funneling
government money your money taxpayer
money into his businesses but there's
another side to this and the Trump
presidency has done some pretty major
damage - one of the things that Donald
Trump values the most which is his brand
and his popularity and whether people
like him this is one of the big
motivators for people like Donald Trump
and for Trump specifically and a lot of
Trump branded condo buildings for
example have removed Donald Trump's name
from them not wanting any association
with Trump even even by name but in
Chicago there's something very
interesting going on the profits at
Trump's Chicago hotel are reportedly
down 89 percent and Trump's company is
saying that violence in Chicago is a
reason for that downturn now understand
profits at Trump's Chicago hotel are
down from nearly 17 million in 2015 to
just 1.8 million in 2018 according to
documents that were filed with Cook
County even though Trump has been
funneling money into that hotel by
holding campaign events there and doing
all of the things that we know him to do
as a president to self enrich the Trump
organizations explanation for this is
that number one Chicago is down as a
market overall and that the perceived
threat of gun violence has harmed visit
a visitation to the destination now the
problem with this explanation is that
gun violence are not down market or not
other hotels in Chicago are doing just
as well or better over the last few
years it's Trump's hotel that is
suffering interestingly as well Donald
Trump's Washington DC hotel which of
course has been patronized by all sorts
of world leaders and diplomats when they
visit DC is also struggling and Eric
Trump recently said quote this is just
an amazing thing to say people are
objecting to us making so much money on
the hotel and therefore we may be
willing to sell it maybe abandoning that
biz
altogether I love how Eric says it like
it's unfair yeah people are objecting to
having a profit center blocks from the
White House from which you self enrich
thanks to being President of the United
States people have a problem with that
and rightly so
and rightly so so Trump and his kids you
know they love to repeat that the
presidency has been terrible for them
financially because they stepped back
Trump has separated from the businesses
they're great moral ethical people who
have missed out on a lot of money they
could have made if Trump wasn't
president do not be confused being
president has allowed Donald Trump in
totally new ways to funnel money
directly into his pocket but there are
also some specific cases where even
Donald Trump's corruption and
self-enrichment attempts can't override
the DNC has done
there are specific cases see in DC in
Chicago as examples where Trump being
president has so disgusted people that
they simply aren't going to his hotels
that's a good thing but it doesn't make
Donald from self-enrichment schemes any
less disgusting as far as it involves
the golf clubs and all of the other
stuff that we've talked about let me
know your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman follow me there follow the show
on Twitter at David Pakman show as well
check out the forecast fest podcast for
the latest election news including
debate previews and recaps and analysis
of how voters are leaning in the early
primary States every week the hosts
Harry Anton Kate Baldwin and John Avlon
bring you the data and the analysis that
you need to get smart and stay smart
this election season they not only give
you the up to date forecasts on who's
ahead and behind in the race for the
White House in Congress they don't just
give you the what but they give you the
all-important why if you want to
understand how the impeachment inquiry
could affect the 2020 presidential race
or you need a refresher on jungle
primaries or polling methods if you want
to get a unique planet political
analysis rooted in data on major
campaign issues like health care and
climate change including historical
context and the latest polling Harry
Keitt and John have you covered
subscribe now to the forecast fest to
stay informed of every twist and turn on
the road to November of 2020 available
wherever you listen to podcasts